GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS RULES WHAT IS
CALLED ORDER. A PREVIEW VICE IN
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS BE MADE AND
IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM HERE
CORREO YEAH FOR GRAYSON
KAMMERER MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
WORKS OVER HERE ROBERT SCHEER
RIVAS LIVING HERE WE HAVE A
CORE WE HAVE A QUORUM- AND WE
HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA. MISTER
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO REQUEST THAT
WE MOVE ITEMS TWO THROUGH SIX
OFF OF CONSENT AND VOTE
INDIVIDUALLY. OKAY THEN WE HAVE
A WILL TAKE UP. WE'LL TAKE UP
THE PRIOR. WHAT WILL TAKE A
SECOND REMINDER SOMETIMES
MANAGE TO BRIDGE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I CARILLO CARILLO
AYE FLORA. LARA AYE GRAYSON AYE
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE PERK
SILVA SILVA AYE RAMOS RAMOS I
RIVAS. RIVAS AYE LEVINE LEVINE
AYE MOTION PASSAGE. MOTIONS
PASSED IS THERE A MOTION ON
ITEMS TWO THROUGH SIX. MOVER
MISTER GRAYSON CENTER BY MISS
CREELMAN INSTRUCTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. COOLEY HIGH FULLY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
FLORA FOR NOT VOTING GRAYSON
GRAYSON I'D KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS SHOWBOATING MATHIS NOT
BOATING PERKS SILVA. RICK SILVA
IRA MOST RAMOS I REFINISH RIVAS
AYE LEVINE. LEVINE I AM NOT
MOTION PASSES MOST OF FRANCE
AND THIS RULES WAS RETURNED WE
WILL TURN THE CHAMBERS.